Let's begin with talquitamib as bridging therapy before CAR-T. Many of you are familiar with
the data that's been published, mostly retrospective work, where talquitamib has shown its efficacy.
The question is, should it become a standard of care?
And if it does, then how do we go about post-CAR-T relapses and where does talquitamib fit
in there and resistant mechanisms?
Okay, so these are my disclosures.
So talquitamib you can see here is part of the NCCN recommendations.
I think it got cut off, but there is at the bottom star an indication saying that talquitamib
can be used as a bridging therapy.
So but why GPRC 5D bridging?
We have a gap of almost six to eight weeks where the CAR-T cells get manufactured from
the time of apheresis to the actual patient getting infected.
And by this time, patients may have already been exposed to your conventional, you know, your POMs and your IMIDs and your carfilzomibs, unless it's really second-line myeloma.
And so, it offers, it's a new target because it preserves your BCMA as that's going to be your CAR-T-cell target.
You don't want to use the BCMA by specifics.
And I know Dr. Garfall made a comment about the cohort C in CAR-T, but there is some reduced efficacy when we follow one BCMA by another BCMA.
And we try not to use conventional chemotherapy because that might compromise T-cell, have an impact on T-cell biology.
So, I think with GPRC5D, especially if it's done post-apheresis, you preserve BCMA, your T-cell fitness is protected.
And then you have rapid-onset disease control.
In my practice, I sometimes just do the ramp-up and not even a full cycle.
That allows for enough disease control where I don't have to expose them to longer durations of the telcoidamab and bring on toxicity.
And so, that makes itself be sufficient.
So, we have two single institution experiences that I present here.
One is the UAB and the other one is the Emory with, you know, patient, about eight patients to 25 patients.
And over here, many of them were, you know, median line, prior lines of therapy were four.
So, these were heavily pre-treated patients.
And then they go on to have high numbers of efficacy.
So, five out of six patients where patients received telcoidamab in the God-B abstract and 22 out of the 25 patients who received telcoidamab.
And then I think there is a work done by Dr. Fundrea.
And where they show that, look at 52 patients who've got in-tech telcoidamab, conventional chemotherapy, and anti-CD38.
And I think that patients who had bispecific bridging therapy had 100% overall response rate versus 46% with other bridges.
And then in terms of CAR-T kinetics, you saw early CD4 and delayed CD8 expansion, which may be independently associated with deep responses.
And then in terms of...
And then in terms of clonal dynamics, higher T-cell colonality at apheresis, which may prime for CAR-T cell synergy.
This is the U.S. Myeloma Immunotherapy Consortium had a study led by Dr. Tuckall, where they looked at 134 patients, both who received Cilta-Cell and Ida-Cell as standard of care.
19 patients did have telcoidamab prior to apheresis, and 115 patients had it after apheresis.
Ultimately, out of the 100, so 89% received it.
And then of these, 15 patients did not get infused.
There were seven progressions, and there was manufacturing failure and patient decision.
So ultimately, out of the 100, 1998 were Cilta-Cell and 21 were Ida-Cell.
And you can see over here with the median follow-up 6.9 months in this 134 patients, the median PFS and overall survival was not reached.
EMD was the only independent predictor of inferior PFS and OS.
And then you can see that 42% of the patients deepened their response after CAR-T versus their telcoidamab response.
The Sankey diagram even illustrates that, you know, 19% of patients achieved CR before CAR-T with just telcoidamab alone.
And then even post-CAR-T responses deepened.
15 patients, as I mentioned before, never reached infusion.
So if the patients who responded to telcoidamab had deeper responses post-CAR-T.
Now let's talk about toxicity.
Dr. Krishnan did mention that in her presentation.
So 60% of GPRC5D specific toxicities were seen, but they were mostly grade 1 and 2, and they did end up resolving.
70% of patients had oral changes, 38% of the patients had skin changes, and grade 3 and 4 was less than 1%.
And the nail changes were only 17%.
And these were probably low because the duration and exposure of the bispecific was not prolonged.
I think the median on days were about 23% and also doing this as we go into CAR-T, GPRC, you know, with GPRC bispecifics, you tend to preserve your humoral response immunity and so you don't get hypogamma and increase your risk of infection.
So that's that.
But I think when we use this, I'm very pleased in seeing this response.
And I use it, but I don't think I use it willy-nilly.
If I can use, if someone doesn't have a high burden of disease and they are not heavily refractory, I tend to go with my carfilzavib, my IMIDS, in first and after first relapse or second relapse.
Because we now have data in terms of a study that Dr. Krishnan highlighted by Holly Lee from Dr. Nizar's lab showing that, you know, patients who had gotten prior GPRCs,
they didn't have a high burden of disease and they had a high risk of getting GPRC bispecifics, they didn't have a high risk of getting GPRC bispecifics.
So one of the main mechanisms in which they relapsed was that there was a large release in their GPRC, GPRC 5D locus, there were monolithic losses, which can lead to reduced GPRC expression on the surface and, and so, you know, we don't, we don't want to lose this as a treatment option, I think even post-CAR-T-T.
So that's why I don't tend to willy-nilly use it.
I reserve it for patients where I don't, I don't want to do chemotherapy, but they have a decent burden of disease.
And my other viable, effective treatment options just don't, are not, are not available to me because we do now have some even evidence of these patients who are GPRC and BCMA refractory.
So your haptic refractory patients and their outcomes and their median overall survival is 12.8 months.
And at the bottom, you can see one of the mechanisms of where we see the mutation.
Sorry.
So I think for questions for debate, should talc bridge before BCMA-CAR-T-T become the standard of care?
What is the optimal washout?
This is something I, we debate all the time.
If I can extend the time between my last talc dose to my CAR-T, I do, keeping in mind the patient's tempo and disease in mind.
And what should actually be your response measure?
What should it be your soluble BCMA decline?
I have that test available at my institution, many, many other places that don't.
And I think does the short course.
I think it's a good question.